-Hi, Santa.
-Hello, Ding Dongs.
-You're looking at me
like I'm on your naughty list.
-Well, I was counting my toys
and was one doinker short.
-I'm going to ask you
for some silly words --
nouns, verbs,
adjectives, et cetera --
and as you do that,
they're going to be
written onto cue cards.
And then we're going to act out
a dramatic Mad Libs scene.
You ready for this?
-Yes, sir.
-Okay. Type of dessert.
-Ding Dong.
Plural or...
-Yeah, Ding Dongs.
Like, you know --
-Yeah, Ding Dongs. Yeah, I know.
Yeah, I love them.
-A silly word.
-Doinker.
-Another word for father.
-Well, doinker, but...papa.
-Aww.
Give me give me a year.
-200 A.D.
-Celebrity name.
-Jennifer Lawrence.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
-Type of plant.
-Uh...apple tree.
It's a plant.
-Yeah, sure.
I guess you plant it, yeah,
outside as a tree.
Yeah, you do. Absolutely.
-I should have said fern.
-That's alright. Adjectives.
-Demure.
Something you'd name a pet.
-Pickles.
-Name of a band.
-The Roots!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Plural animal.
-Gerbils.
-Verb ending in "-ing."
-Spanking.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give me...
Give me a number.
-22.
-Measurement of time.
-Century.
-Centuries.
-Centuries. A body part.
♪♪
-The nad.
[ Laughter ]
"The nad."
A type of beer.
-Milwaukee's Best Ice.
-[ Laughs ]
-The good stuff.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Milwaukee's Best Ice
better send me some
Milwaukee's Best Ice.
-Type of doctor.
-Pediatrician.
-One-syllable noise.
-Ugh!
Is that right?
-Yeah.
-It's a syllable.
-No, that "Ugh" is good.
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah, this is all good.
There's no wrong answers.
-Okay.
-Plural noun.
-Mm-hmm.
-Forks.
-There's only two more.
Mode of transportation.
-Starship.
-And holiday.
-Christmas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whew!
-We filled out the words
for the scene.
Are you ready to perform it?
-Okay, yes.
-Let's go.
Here we go. Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bells jingling ]
♪♪
-Hi, Santa.
-Hello, Ding Dongs.
-You're looking at me
like I'm on your naughty list.
-Well, I was counting my toys
and was one doinker short.
I believe you stole it.
-But, Papa...
-I started making that toy
in 200 A.D.
What will the little
Jennifer Lawrences think
when she wakes up
on Christmas morning
with nothing
under the apple tree?
-I would never steal
such a demure toy.
-Where were you the night
before Christmas?
-I was with Pickles.
We were listening to
The Roots' holiday album
and making snow gerbils.
-Nice.
-Pickles is very...
-Hmm. Mm-hmm!
Then why did Rudolph
see you spanking on the roof?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
22 centuries
before the toy was missing.
-That's a coincidence.
-The reason I work so hard
is because I get to spread joy
to millions of people
and go sit by the fire,
shaking my nad.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-The little...
-I know, I know, I know.
-Tiny, little guy.
-Yeah, yeah.
-While eating cookies and
drinking Milwaukee's Best Ice.
-Fine. I stole the toy.
[ High-pitched ]
But I only did it...
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
-I was using
a fake voice earlier.
-Oh.
-I'm an elf.
I forgot I was an elf.
-Oh, right.
Oh, and I'm Santa.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
-That's right.
Ding Dongs. Ho-ho.
You're silly.
-I sold the toy.
I only did it because I wanted
to impress my pediatrician.
-Ugh! Ugh! Ugh!
Every time there's
a holiday miracle,
I sing my favorite
Christmas song, "Jingle Forks."
[ Bells jingling ]
♪ Jingle forks, Jingle forks ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ In a one-horse open starship ♪
-Merry Christmas, Santa!
Hey!
-Yeah!
-Scene!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, here we go.
-Okay, this is great.
-Right?
-Yeah.
-Give me an adjective.
-Ah, flamboyant.
[ Laughter ]
-Flamboyant.
-Mm-hmm.
Really making
our cue-card guys work.
Pet name.
-Winston.
-Wow, that was really fast.
Nickname for a kid.
-Jimmy Bill Bob.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
That's a nickname for a kid?
-Yeah. Jimmy Bill Bob.
-Type of profession.
-Late-night host.
[ Laughter ]
-What would you shout
if you stubbed your toe?
-Falafel!
[ Laughter ]
-Give me a number.
-6-8-0-1.
-Gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Give me a made-up fact
about chickens.
-They can fly.
-Oh.
-Two words that rhyme.
-Fallon, talon.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't have to make
the whole thing about me.
Type of food.
-Ooh!
That's a tough one.
I'll let you go with that one.
-What? No.
-I have to do it?
-This is a game. It's fun.
It's John Cena saying any food.
-Ballpark hot dog.
[ Laughter ]
These are the most interesting
answers I've ever played.
Type of drink.
-A Rob Roy.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-It's a Manhattan with a --
-I know what that is, but no kid
knows what a Rob Roy is!
-They do now.
Rob Roys for everyone!
-Rob Roys for everyone here,
yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rob Roy is great.
A verb ending in "-ing."
-Uh, begrudging?
No, that's begrudgingly?
No, no.
Uh...
Um, running, running, running.
-Running, very good.
Running.
-I had to go basic.
I was trying to go complicated.
-Advice that you would give
a shy teenager.
-Stay golden, Pony Boy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-These are
the best answers ever.
Stay golden, Pony Boy.
Oh, my gosh.
-It's a safe one.
-Another good reference.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughing ]
Body part.
-Perineum.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna have
to give my cue-card guy
mouth-to-mouth after perineum.
-Well, I can't --
I mean, that's --
You want to go medical on that.
-No, no, perineum.
Is that something?
-Oh, it's the space between --
-Okay, got you.
[ Laughter ]
That's not
what that song is about.
-That is for me.
-No, it is not.
-That's how
Dave Matthews speaks to me!
-That's not what it's about.
Oh, my gosh.
-Here we are. This is your game.
-No, I know. This is great.
Object.
-Protractor.
[ Laughter ]
-A plural noun.
-Puppies.
-Aww.
-Plural animals.
-Dragons.
[ Laughter ]
-What would you say
if you found out
you got an A-plus
on your chemistry test?
-"Teacher, my name's not Dave!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-'Cause I wouldn't --
I would never...
-Got it.
Alright, we're almost done.
Give me a color.
-Hmm, sea breeze.
[ Laughter ]
-Sea breeze is a color?
I got to get my Crayola set.
Another profession.
-WWE superstar.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright!
Couple of fans in the house.
-Yeah.
-Appreciate it.
-Two more. Another body part.
-[ Laughs ]
-Can I say anus?
-No!
Yes, you can.
You can say it.
-It's a part.
-And a verb.
-Uh, jump.
-There we go.
Perfect.
Alright, we filled it out.
We are ready for our scene.
I'm gonna hand this in
to the computer.
[ Laughter ]
And then they're going
to go on the cue cards.
Are you ready
to perform our scene?
-Let's do this!
-Yes! Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ah, I love Christmas.
It's the most
flamboyant time of the year.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Hey, what's wrong?
-There's something
I have to tell you, Winston.
-What is it, Jimmy Bill Bob?
[ Laughter ]
I'm your brother
and your best late-night host.
You can tell me anything.
-Well, this isn't easy,
but here it goes.
I don't believe in Santa Claus.
-Falafel!
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, hey.
I understand
why you would react that way.
We've been writing Santa
letters every day
for the past 6-8-0-1 decades.
[ Laughter ]
-This is more shocking than when
I found out chickens can fly.
[ Laughter ]
What made you stop believing?
-All I wanted for Christmas
was the most popular toy
everyone had, the Fallon Talon.
[ Laughter ]
I left Santa
a plate of ballpark hot dogs
and a glass of Rob Roy,
but on Christmas morning,
there was
nothing under the tree.
So I ran to my room and
started running.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-Little bro,
I'm gonna tell you
the same thing Dad used to tell
me every night before bed.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-[ Coughing ]
-Yes?
What -- What is that?
-Stay golden, Pony Boy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
Stay golden --
Stay golden, Pony Boy.
[ Laughter ]
-Truer words
have never been spoken.
-Look, all you have to do
is look deep...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
...within your per--
"Perenium."
-Perineum.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You remember
Dad used to say that, as well.
[ Laughter ]
You got to look deep...
for the holiday spirit.
Come on, man. You can do it.
-You're right, brother.
The holidays are magical.
Decorating
the Christmas protractor.
[ Laughter ]
Hanging the puppies
on the mantel.
[ Laughter ]
And spending time
with all my dragons.
[ Laughter ]
I believe again!
There is a Santa Claus!
-Teacher, my name's not Dave!
-You know, the best part
about believing in Santa
is getting to sing
my favorite song with you.
-[ Laughs ]
You sure you don't
want to do it by yourself?
[ Laughter ]
-Which is...?
-What is the song?
-"Rudolph the Sea-Breeze-Nosed
WWE Superstar."
[ Laughter ]
Man, I screwed myself on that.
-That is my favorite song.
Let's sing!
[ Clears throat ]
♪ Rudolph the sea-breeze-nosed
WWE Superstar ♪
♪ Had a very shiny anus ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ And if you ever saw it ♪
-Jumped.
-♪ You would even say
it jumped ♪
And scene.
Go run to your room.